As with everything else,
when building an app for Geo Fencing,
you'll need a GoogleAPIClient.
You've seen these earlier in the course,
and you've seen how to set them up, so
let's assume at this point
that you've done that.
In order for your app to monitor
the GeoFences, you have to define them.
And a GeoFence is defined
using the GeoFence object,
which you create using
a GeoFence Builder.
It takes the following properties.
Latitude and longitude define where
the GeoFence is in the world.
These are just the typical latitude and
longitude that define
any location anywhere.
The radius defines a circular area
around the latitude and longitude.
This determines how close
the user needs to be
to that location from any direction
before any alert gets triggered.
The expiration time determines how
long the fence should remain active.
Once this time expires,
the GeoFence is deleted.
And you can of course set up
permanent ones if you like.
And the GeoFence ID is
an identifier to use so
that you can know which
GeoFence has been triggered.
This should be unique.
If you consider the fact that GeoFences
are based on latitude and longitude and
a circle around them, you can actually
have GeoFences that overlap each other.
When a user enters a particular space,
they may trigger two or more GeoFences.
As such, as a developer,
you may want to know which ones, and
you do that using
the ID of the GeoFence.
Now, I'm going to define a GeoFence
as looking something like this.
You can then define a number of
GeoFences as an array of GeoFence
objects.
So, I'm going to wrap the list of
GeoFences in ArrayList like this.
Once you have your
ArrayList of GeoFences,
you can then use
a GeoFencingRequest class
simply by calling its addGeoFences
method and passing the ArrayList to it.
Once this is working, you can then add
the GeoFencingRequest to your client and
specify a pending intent that is
used to process the call backs
from the location services API.
This pending intent
uses an intent service
in a similar way to the address
example that we saw earlier.
Now, whenever a GeoFencing
action happens,
the intent service will catch it,
and it will route it to your app.